um
okay don't know why i'm doing this
cd cd
okay i think this is
not considered that accurate
i'm supposed to be like a little bit
better here
but whether i can prove it that's a
that's a very big f should just go f3 g4
okay i'm just i guess i'm just gonna go
for it
you can always go bishop c2 whenever he
tries to attack d4
and now kh1 i suppose
it's a bit weird okay queen d3
f8 i guess i'm going rook g1 trying for
g5 at some point
yeah it's not so easy for him to play
here
um i can go f4
because i can just continue developing
for the moment
queen f6 is meant by knight d5
now i gotta have four right i'm missing
something tactically
i don't think so
this is probably quite strong
yeah rook f1 and then f5
looks very very good
okay i'm just going to fly
g5 is coming next
still g5 right
it's got knight d4 then worker 4
i don't think he has anything there
takes queenish five still alive which is
a bit annoying
take it i guess
one two four
okay you can take it
without the queen his king is he's gonna
be way too weak i think
queen g3 yeah this is game over h6
knight of sixers queen h4 king g7 queen
g5
okay let me
you